ce sens le procès d'outreau s'achève
mais le débat est loin d'être terminée
deux mois d'audiences marquées par de
nombreux dysfonctionnements et de
nombreux rebondissements pour certains
accusés aujourd'hui à quitter mail
longtemps incarcéré bien cette affaire
sera impossible à oublier le reportage
de nathalie cause et xavier de pertes a
quitté pierre martel espère se
reconstruire oublié peut-être cette
erreur judiciaire
avec sa femme il a toujours clamé son
innocence en vain jusqu'à ses fruits 30
mois de prison accusé de pédophilie
une vie broyer il y a quelques jours ils
croisent un enfant une rencontre banale
il s'est enfui les pleurs de son enfant
donc ça c'est pas ce n'est pas un
comportement normal c'était tard ça
commence
c'est dans ce genre de situation que je
veux essayer de rétablir si vous voulez
je ne veux plus avoir peur d'un enfant
janvier 2001 le juge burgaud ici l
écharpe noire vient d'être nommé
magistrat il est seul face à un réseau
présumé de pédophiles les enfants sont
crédibles pour les experts alors le juge
refuse toutes les demandes des accusés
pour roselyne normande pas de
confrontation avec les victimes
pas de contre expertise vous a dit le
juge la première fois quand vous êtes
rentré dans son bureau
l'acteur du siècle il avoué ou vous fait
perdre mon temps
le point marquant de ces instructions à
chaque fois qu'on demande et des mises
en liberté on disait ah
attention les enfants sont les enfants
sont crédibles donc ils disent la vérité
ce qui est une catastrophe thouars
puisque on demande pas aux experts
contre x de dire si l'enfant dise la
vérité on demande aux experts de parler
d'un traumatisme éventuels liés à une
éventuelle agression sexuelle ces
experts sont désavoués par la cour
d'assises pour de nouveaux experts au
contraire la parole des enfants fragiles
construits sur les mensonges de myriam
badaoui l'instruction s'effondre que
elle discuterait accusé entendu de
multiples fois les enfants aussi se
contredit les conditions d'audition des
enfants aussi bien devant la police que
dans le cas des expertises que surtout
devant des cours d'assises sont tout à
fait insatisfaisante on peut pas se
contenter de ça ceux qui ont été
incarcérés puis acquitté peuvent
aujourd'hui seulement demander une
indemnisation